we've heard of text to speech text to
video and text to action but have we
slept on text to interaction let's take
a look at the new Genie concept from
Google Deep Mind and set it in the
context of new developments regarding
Sora and Gemini and we'll hear what
Demis sais CEO of Google deepmind has to
say about samman's $7 trillion chip
Ambitions and touch on some recent
notorious missteps but I do want to make
a confession upfront to all of you guys
the entire industry will not be shocked
by this video Everything might not
change and the world may well not be
stunned by what I have to say if you're
willing to forgive that it should still
be an interesting time so let's get
started the tldr of Genie released in
the last few days is this you can now
hand a relatively small AI model an
image and it could be any image a photo
you've just taken on on your phone a
sketch that your child or you just drew
or an image of course that you generated
using say mid Journey or darly 3 and
Genie that small model will take this
image and make it interactive a bit like
handing you a Playstation or Xbox
controller you could then make the main
character jump go left go right and the
scene will change around it essentially
you've made an image playable or in
other words you've made imaginary worlds
interactive this is how Google put it
Genie is capable of converting a variety
of different prompts into interactive
playable environments these can be
easily created stepped into and explored
now before we get into the meat of the
paper I want to let your imagination run
wild because your mind of course went to
the same place as me which is Imagine
This integrated into Sora how about
controlling the shark or dolphin in this
paper craft world remember that the
promise of this paper is that as you
move left right up down or make jumping
motions the world is crafted around you
this would be open world exploration in
its truest sense or take this example
again generated by Sora in the near
future we needn't have two separate
models either it could be the same model
generating the world and allowing you to
interact within it and yes I do still
find it incredible that this video was
generated by Sora and the characters you
create could take almost any form how
about a tortoise made of glass or maybe
you want to control a translucent
jellyfish floating through a
post-apocalyptic cityscape or how about
this example yes it's nice to watch the
video but imagine controlling it so it
would be prompted by an image say of
your hometown and I can't help but point
out the speed with which many of us are
now becoming accustomed to new
announcements and how we're adjusting to
them open AI Sora model has been out for
just over a week and here's a paper
where we can imagine it being
interactive but that's the way things
are going modalities are multiplying
models are unifying across text audio
video action and interaction in a moment
I'll touch on how this might affect
robotics but here's audio coming to
videos generated by Sora this is thanks
to 11 labs and you can just feel how
sound elevates the experience of video
all of this 30second clip is AI
generated
in a place beyond imagination where the
Horizon kisses the heavens one man dares
to Journey where few have
ventured armed with nothing but his wit
and an unyielding Spirit he seeks the
answers to Mysteries that lie beyond the
stars and there's one key detail that I
don't want you to miss from the genie
paper the final version of Genie at 11
billion parameters was trained in an
unsupervised manner from unlabeled
internet videos to simplify they didn't
pair up an image with some controller
movements or text and tell the model
what happened next there was no such
human supervision it was just hundreds
of thousands of Internet videos and if
you don't find that interesting well how
about this the results they got from the
genie architecture scale gracefully they
say with additional computational
resources if you want Sora levels of
fidelity rather than the pixelated stuff
we got just scale up the compute then as
the paper says we will have generative
interactive environments which is a new
paradigm whereby interactive
environments can be generated from a
single text or image prompt at this
point though before we get carried away
I want to inject some realism Genie was
trained on 10 frames per second video
clips at 160x 90 resolution for the
website they scaled up to 360p but still
we are not yet that close to Sora levels
of immersion and interaction and I don't
just mean that Sora and the genie
interactions hallucinate badly according
to the paper I'm referring to the fact
that real time High Fidelity generation
is still a while away that's just not on
my prediction list for this year and
that's despite me saying that super
realistic text video would happen this
year in my January 1st video what's my
evidence that latency will slow
everything down well according to
Bloomberg open AI won't say precisely
how long Sora takes on each request but
apparently you can definitely go grab a
snack while you wait for these things to
run so real time interactive low
resolution games by the end of this year
yes and high resolution time limited
interactive Generations by the end of
this year but I think we'll have to wait
till next year for the combination of
those two things still I do think it's
worth pausing to imagine a scenario that
we might well get by the end of this
year be it inside Gemini 2 or GPT 5
imagine either of those models creating
an intricate short story say with this
cute little robot character as the
protagonist and then alongside each
chapter of that story it generates a
real-time video that you can play about
with you can almost picture it as the
paper says it would emulate Parallax
that's when the character and the
foreground move around but the
background stays relatively static the
model would have created not only a
story but a playable world and just to
reiterate all we need is a single text
prompt or a single image to create that
new interactive environment we've seen
how it can make an AI image playable but
here is that concept applied to a human
design sketch and finally to some real
world
images but just before we leave the
paper I want to touch on just how well
within their capabilities Google were
when they made this 11 billion parameter
model and let's not even talk about
Gemini 1.5 Ultra which is coming soon or
Gemini 2 What could they do with a
bigger model size or more compute well
they could train Genie 2 on an even
larger proportion of Internet videos to
simulate realistic and imagined
environments at this point I'll even
throw in another prediction I think by
the end of this year you could play a
run through of a particular game from
start to end then feed in that entire
video to say Genie 2 or an open source
equivalent then if you wait a few
minutes you'll essentially get an
expansion pack another level of the game
generated by the model one which might
have some hallucinations but in which
you can take all the same actions as
before for of course the copyright
issues with that will be multifarious
but there are some other complications
aside from copyright about all of these
developments and no I don't just mean an
explosion of cheating in gaming you can
now buy monitors that alert you of enemy
movements and you're going to get AI
powered peripherals that ensure you
don't miss your shots but frankly for me
take away the spirit of any game but no
I'm more referring to the growing
unpredictability of the job market not
necessarily job losses but the inability
to plan your career like this
announcement from Tyler Perry isn't
exactly about Job losses he saw open AI
Sora last week and decided not to expand
his Studio but those quote job losses
wouldn't show up necessarily in the
statistics because those jobs never
necessarily existed it's just that they
won't exist now let me know what you
think but I feel like that might happen
quite a lot it's not that companies
might start to fire everyone they just
might not hire as many people as they
originally would have done and it almost
goes without saying that that doesn't
just apply to gaming and entertainment
Samsung and I raised an eyebrow at this
plans to have fully automated chip
fabrication plants by 2030 and that
article brought to mind this one minute
video that I think is appropriate to
play here looking to upskill for the
future this new AI can perform all
coding jobs in seconds including
blockchain
development while this AI is already
outperforming accounting firms
meanwhile the new graphic design AI aims
to automate graphic design and could
minimize the
relax cuz in a future where AI does most
of the work there'll be one thing that
humans will finally get to do all day
long
nothing before we lose all of our jobs
though a quick plug for the new Discord
Channel I've got set up for AI insiders
I've recruited thought leaders from 20
professions from neurosurgeons to
professors cyber Security Experts
marketing CEOs and AI engineers and new
people are joining as thought leaders
every week including a famous game
designer hopefully next week what we're
trying to create is a friendly and
professional environment in which to
swap tips and share best practices of
course I'd love to see you there but if
you join my patreon you don't of course
just get access to the Discord there's
also podcasts and interviews tomorrow
actually I'm interviewing the CEO ofp
and last but not least exclusive AI
explain Style videos this is one that I
released 4 days ago that draws upon
seven or eight different papers this is
the same week though that Demis Aris
gently mocked that $7 trillion figure he
was asked inwi about samman trying to
raise that much money for more AI chips
to scale up the compute available deis
haris the CEO of Google Deep Mind said
this was that a misquote I heard someone
say that maybe it was Yen or something
of course taking the Mickey because yen
is worth a lot less than dollars he went
on to point out that of course not
everything rests on scale he said you're
not going to get new capabilities like
planning or tool use or agent-like
behavior just by scaling existing
techniques I've got another video coming
on agents so that discussion we'll have
to wait for another day but what might
be coming sooner than that video is a
video on AI in robotics 4 days ago a
researcher at Google Deep Mind said this
there will be three to four massive news
events coming out in the next weeks that
will rock the robotics plus AI space
adjust your timelines it will be a crazy
2024 now I would guess that Genie counts
as one of those three to four
announcements he can't have been
referring to Gemma the open model from
Google deep mind because that was
released the day before the most
interesting part of the Gemma paper and
release for me was the sheer scale of
data that they used for those of you
who've been following the scene for a
while and remember the chinchilla paper
that was back in 2022 when it was
discovered that for a given compute
budget the optimum number of tokens to
train on text tokens we're talking about
was roughly 20 times the number of
parameters but for Gemma which was seven
or 8 billion parameters they trained on
around 6 trillion tokens of text that's
a th000 tokens of text for every
parameter or in other words when you've
got the kind of compute that Google has
you don't have to necessarily follow the
compute optimal strategy but I am pre
invting what news do I think Ted is
referring to well here's my best guess
and no it's not based on any Insider
knowledge I think Google is going to
announce another embodied model like rt2
but powered by Gemini now I've covered
rt2 in previous videos back in October
and indeed interviewed the tech lead for
RT 2x for AI insiders but those models
in a nutshell fuse robotics data with
transferred learning from text and web
data in other words it got better at
robotics through having an llm at its
core or you might say an mmm a
multimodal model but in the case of rt2
that was palm e at 12 billion parameters
or parley X at 55 billion parameters
imagine rt3 powered by Gemini at say one
trillion parameters it might understand
the world around it to unprecedented
degrees of depth and intelligence and if
it's powered by Gemini 1.5 it might be
able to remember that world for months
and months and months indeed I was so
inspired by the RT series that I made it
The Unofficial logo of AI insiders the
evaluations for humanoid AI powered
robotic startups are starting to get
pretty wild too the CEO of Nvidia Jensen
hang said that his equivalent for the
Transformer paper in the near future is
foundational robotics he said if you
could generate text if you could
generate images can you also generate
motion he said the answer is probably
yes and like we've seen we can also
generate interaction he went on humanoid
robotics should be just around the
corner I think he was referring to
nvidia's gear generalist embodied agent
research that's led by none other than
Jim fan and he said 2024 is the year of
Robotics and the year of gaming AI now
this is Tesla's Optimus robot but I do
wonder if the Chachi PT or Sora moment
for robotics will be when a humanoid
robot walks with the fluidity of a human
that will just seems so wild when it
happens just imagine a humanoid walking
up to you with humanlike SW wagger and
shaking your hand all while remembering
a conversation you had with it say a
year ago now I don't think I can end
this video without touching on some of
the recent controversies that Google has
faced I just think they were fairly
clearly not given the kind of testing
that they obviously required and I'm not
just referring to how Gemini seems to be
phobic of the word white there's also
evidence of false refusals to questions
that have a pretty obvious answer and my
take on this is going to try to move
Beyond just the obvious take I think
these examples show that Google is
genuinely rattled by open AI Microsoft
and players like perplexity and so
they're cutting corners on the testing
of their models after all if you're 6
months behind open aai What's one way to
catch up just cut out 6 months of human
feedback for your models I hope this
isn't what Google did or plans to do in
the future but it seems like that to me
so let me know what you think of all of
this and whether we are indeed entering
a new era of action and interaction
thank you so much for watching all the
way to the end and have a wonderful day